[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
metry Sirin ihnen allen guten Abend
Norbert du hast später Biathlon und
Champions League im Angebot und Ski
Alpin oben drauf schönen guten Abend
auch von mir und das haben wir heute
unter anderem für Sie vorbereitet
Ringen um weitere Militärhilfe in
Brüssel fordert die Ukraine vom Westen
Kampfjets die nato-mehrheit will vorerst
aber nur Munition und Panzer liefern
Sicherheitslücken bei Infrastruktur der
Bau der neuen flüssiggast Terminals ging
schnell sicher vor Hackerangriffen und
Sabotage sind sie offenbar noch nicht
und Schrumpfkur auf dem Weg zur
Elektromobilität Ford streicht in der
Produktentwicklung fast jede zweite
Stelle verzichtet aber auf
betriebsbedingte Kündigungen
[Musik]
wichtiger Termin heute in Brüssel die
Nato-Verteidigungsminister haben über
weitere Militärhilfen für Kiew beraten
es ging um Kampfjets aber vor allem um
stotternde kampfpanzerlieferungen und
Munition die die Ukraine dringend
braucht erstmalig mit dabei
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius Florian
neuhahn über Zustand Ziele und noch
fehlende Zusagen der Nato-Partner
wenn es um plastische Bilder für die
Fernsehkameras geht dann liefert die
ukrainische Regierung zuverlässig heute
mit dem Verteidigungsminister aus Kiew
zu Gast bei der NATO in Brüssel die
Forderung auf seinem einstecktuch
was ist das sehen Sie das Kampfjet
doch liefert der Westen was die Ukraine
seit Wochen vehement fordert aus dem
kategorischen Nein ist zumindest bei
manchen die selbst über Kampf des
verfügen ein vielleicht geworden
wir nehmen immer ernst was die Ukraine
fordert natürlich das ist ein komplexes
Waffensystem und wir müssen das mit
unseren Partnern diskutieren
allein die Ausbildung von Piloten aber
dauerte Monate eine Lieferung käme
ohnehin zu spät für die aktuellen
Angriffe Russlands helfen dagegen würden
die versprochenen Leopard 2 Kampfpanzer
während Deutschland nun mit der
Ausbildung beginnt halten andere Länder
ihre Zusagen da bisher nicht ein der
deutsche Verteidigungsminister mit
deutlicher Kritik an Polen da sieht es
nicht ganz so berauschend aus und es
vorsichtig zu formulieren insbesondere
auch wohl möglicherweise was den Zustand
und die Einsatzfähigkeit der Panzer
angeht neue zusagen aber bekommt die
Ukraine in Brüssel heute nicht erst
recht nicht zu Kampfjets der Ruf nach
Kampfjets überlagert die aktuell
vielleicht wichtigere Herausforderung
die Ukraine verbraucht aktuell deutlich
mehr Munition als der Westen ihr liefern
kann
immerhin das Problem ist erkannt die
Munition für den bereits gelieferten
Gepard flugabwehrpanzer soll künftig in
Deutschland produziert werden
Produktionsbeginn allerdings erst im
Sommer
in Rake für uns Katrin Eigendorf Katrin
während die NATO auf mehr Munition
drängt sich die Lage im Osten der
Ukraine weiter zu ganz besonders in
bachmut was kannst du uns berichten
ja was wir im Moment in bachmut erleben
ist wahrscheinlich eine der schlimmsten
und brutalsten Schlachten die wir bisher
in diesem Krieg erlebt haben beide
Seiten stehen sich hier seit geraumer
Zeit gegenüber und keine Seite weich
zurück das die besondere Problematik für
die ukrainische Armee ist dass es hier
nicht nur mit russischen Truppen zu tun
haben sondern mit denen als besonders
brutal bekannten Söldnern der
wagnergruppe was man hier auch sieht
dass eben westliche Waffen nicht
rechtzeitig kamen das ist an Waffen und
Munition fehlt um wirklich die russische
Armee hier zurückzuschlagen und sich
effektiv verteidigen zu können es ist so
dass inzwischen Hilfsorganisationen
aufgefordert wurden nicht mehr in die
Stadt zu gehen 5000 Menschen leben dort
noch die werden jetzt nur noch von der
Armee versorgt das heißt die Lage
scheint sich auch aus Sicht der Ukraine
sehr sehr deutlich dahin zu spitzen dass
man möglicherweise über längere
Perspektive bei einem Rückzug nachdenken
muss vielen Dank nach Katrin Eigendorf
eine Folge des Ukraine Krieges Finland
und Schweden wollen in die nahto
Außenministerin Bär Box sicherte Ihnen
heute Unterstützung zu für die Aufnahme
ins Bündnis müssten alle NATO-Staaten
zustimmen die Türkei stellt sich
allerdings bislang quer Andreas kühnerst
begleitet die Ministerin nach Stockholm
und Helsinki
wir sind im Hafen von Helsinki auf der
Brücke des Eisbrechers Polaris
wir sind hier Helsinki da und alle
Schiffe die rot eingezeichnet sind sind
Russisch und sanktioniert es ist nicht
ganz klar ob er auch Ihnen helfen muss
helfen darf Finnland stärkster
Eisbrecher jeder Tag jedes Schiff kann
eine Krise auslösen hier bei Russlands
direkten Nachbarn die deutsche
Außenministerin sichert am Vormittag
Finnlands Präsidenten Minister
Unterstützung zu und am Nachmittag
schwedensaußenminister billström
gemeinsam der Frust über die Blockade
des nato-beitritts es ist eine türkische
Entscheidung die weder Schweden noch
Finnland beeinflussen kann
auf die Frage ob Schweden notfalls ohne
Finnland beitreten sollte antwortet
bärbock nicht sondern ich werbe mit
allem was ich habe dafür dass Finnland
und Schweden schnellstmöglich der NATO
beitreten können weil es in unserem
gemeinsamen NATO Sicherheitsinteresse
ist bei aller Freundlichkeit wer boxt
bitte der Ukraine Leopard 2 Panzer zu
liefern wird in beiden Ländern überhört
auch wenn die Deutschen dann das
versprochene Bataillon nicht zusammen
bekommen solange Schweden und vor allem
Finnland nicht sicher sein können dass
sie in die NATO kommen brauchen sie ihre
Panzer selbst
sich unabhängig machen von russischen
Energie Lieferungen damit konnte es seit
Kriegsbeginn gar nicht schnell genug
gehen im Eiltempo wurden deswegen
lng-terminals im Norden gebaut
eigentlich sollten die Flüssiggasanlagen
besonders geschützt werden und zur
kritischen Infrastruktur zählen nach
Recherchen des ZDF Magazins frontal sind
sie das aber genau nicht Michael
haselrieder
die neuen flüssiggasterminals an Nord-
und Ostsee sind in nur wenigen Monaten
in Betrieb gegangen Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz sprach von einem neuen
Deutschland Tempo doch die LNG Terminals
sein schlecht vor Cyberangriffen und
Sabotage geschützt Räumen selbst
Abgeordnete der Regierungskoalition ein
und fordern und dass man genau diese LNG
Terminals jetzt auch unter diesen Schutz
bekommen muss das sind sie bisher nur
unzureichend deswegen ist es wichtig
dass sie jetzt ähm gegen Hecking
Angriffe geschützt werden nach ZDF
Recherchen gehören die Terminals bisher
nicht einmal zur kritischen
Infrastruktur die besonders geschützt
ist dazu zählen z.B Kraftwerke oder
Energienetze Nachfrage bei der
bundesinnenministerin heute in Warschau
die verweist auf ein geplantes Gesetz
zur kritischen Infrastruktur kurz kritis
wir arbeiten mit Hochdruck und einem
kritisches dachgesetz wo wir Standards
auch definieren wo wir nicht nur die
Standards definieren sondern auch eher
zu kritischen Infrastruktur gehört und
das werden wir sicher mit definieren
zwar überwacht die Polizei die Terminals
auf See und an Land doch der Schutz vor
Cyberangriffen komme bisher zu kurz
kritisiert die Opposition sein Fehler
dass sie bisher nicht geschützt werden
offensichtlich ist die Bundesregierung
selbst überrumpelt worden von der
Geschwindigkeit des Aufbaus es ist
eigentlich ein Skandal und deswegen muss
das so rasch wie möglich verbessert
werden denn vor allem die kritische
Infrastruktur ist im Visier von
prorussischen Hackergruppen
Sicherheitslücken ausgerechnet dort wo
Deutschland besonders verwundbar ist
und mehr dazu auch in frontal heute
Abend um 21 Uhr hier im ZDF schon mehr
als 40.000 Tote in den Erdbebengebieten
die Not kennt keine Grenzen vor allem in
Syrien erreicht die Menschen kaum
internationale Hilfe syriens Präsident
Assad will deshalb zwei weitere
Grenzübergänge im Nordwesten des Landes
öffnen bisher kam entdecken Betten
Lebensmittel ausschließlich über die
Region ins Land über die Lage im
riesigen Erdbebengebiet berichtet
Christoph Destel und beginnt im
türkischen adiamant
Häuser der Stadt in Trümmern
zusammengestürzt vor acht Tagen fast 200
Stunden die der 18-Jährige Mohammed Java
Cetin irgendwie ausgehalten hat der
Moment seiner Rettung
1 2 3 rufen die Helfer und ziehen ihn
aus der Dunkelheit dann sagt der erste
zu Mohammed was habe ich dir versprochen
du kommst hier raus
noch andere zwei Brüder können in
kachtermann madasch gerettet werden am
Krankenbett erzählt der Jüngere wie sie
durchkam
es gab eine Flasche Wasser und mein
Handy am Bett als die Decke um uns
einstürzte damit haben wir es geschafft
Proteinpulver hätten sie auch noch
gehabt und einander sagt er
unfassbares Glück doch der Alltag in der
Katastrophe sieht inzwischen so aus
Wohngebäude stürzen bei Räumarbeiten
endgültig zusammen Menschen sitzen im
Schutt und haben keine Hoffnung mehr für
ihre vermissten Angehörigen
erst hat mein Vater und der den Trümmern
noch nach Hilfe gerufen jetzt ist es zu
spät
auch auf syrischer Seite der Grenze geht
es nicht mehr ums retten Phase 2 nennt
das der un-koordinator in Aleppo es ist
der Blick nach vorne
jetzt brauchen die Menschen Unterkünfte
Essen Schulen und wir müssen ihnen einen
Sinn für ihre Zukunft geben
in die vom Assad-Regime kontrollierte
Gegend kommt dafür inzwischen
einigermaßen Hilfe aber nicht ins
Rebellengebiet im Nordwesten jetzt mit
den drei geöffneten Grenzübergängen zur
Türkei könnte sich das ändern vielleicht
die Betroffenen in der Türkei und Syrien
können jede Unterstützung gebrauchen so
wäre Hilfe möglich sie scannen unten
rechts den
QR-Code dort alle relevanten Infos zum
Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe die
iban.de
65-100
400-00-100 400 600 Stichwort ZDF
Erdbeben Türkei Syrien alle Infos auch
auf spenden.zdf.de und auf der ZDF Text
Seite 89.0
die us-republikanerin Niki Haley will
bei der Präsidentschaftswahl 2024
kandidieren es sei Zeit für einen
generationenwandel so die 51-Jährige sie
ist damit die erste parteiinterne
Herausforderungen von Ex-Präsident Trump
der seine Kandidatur ja bereits vor
Monaten angekündigt hatte während Trumps
Amtszeit war Haley us-botschafterin bei
den Vereinten Nationen 2018 gab sie
diesen Posten überraschend auf
bei der Berliner Wiederholungswahl zum
Abgeordnetenhaus hat es doch eine Panne
gegeben die noch Folgen haben könnte im
Bezirk Lichtenberg sind 450 Wahlbriefe
liegen geblieben und noch nicht
berücksichtigt worden zur Erinnerung
zwischen SPD und Grünen also zwischen
Platz 2 und 3 Lagen insgesamt nur 105
Stimmen im Laufe der Woche sagt der
Landeswahlleiter sollen die neuen Zahlen
dann vorliegen
der US-Autobauer Ford ist im Umbruch
erst relativ spät sprang er in Europa
auf den Zug Elektromobilität auf die
Neuausrichtung kostet jetzt
Arbeitsplätze europaweit sind
3800 Jobs betroffen alleine an den
Standorten Köln und Aachen verlieren
2300 Mitarbeiter in den kommenden drei
Jahren ihre Stelle
1700 davon fallen in der
Entwicklungsabteilung Weg
600 in der Verwaltung und das alles soll
möglichst sozialverträglich gehen Lothar
Becker berichtet
bei der Betriebsversammlung heute wurden
rund 14.000 Beschäftigte über den
geplanten Stellenabbau bei Ford
informiert vor allem im
Entwicklungszentrum in Köln Merkenich
soll nachher zu jeder zweite Stelle
aufgelöst werden allerdings mit
Abfindungen und altersteilzeit-
aber er bleibt in seiner Fähigkeit
bestehen dass wir vor uns ganz wichtig
weil am Anfang der Produkten steht dir
das was am Ende auch irgendwann bauen
der befürchtete große Kahlschlag bleibt
aus Erleichterung in den betroffenen
Abteilungen wir hatten ja damit
gerechnet dass ein ganz harte Maßnahmen
ergriffen werden dass wir
Entlassung geht und jetzt die Sicherheit
zu haben dass nicht entlassen wird
sondern ja vorsichtig abgebaut wirklich
frei gemacht und durch unheimlich
beruhigend wir freuen uns erstmal
positiv die schwierigen Zeiten kommen
jetzt noch aber das werden wir auch
schaffen glaube ich
denn in Köln geht eine
Ära zu Ende die Produktion des hier
entwickelten Fiesta läuft im Sommer aus
ab dann baut fort hier ein Elektro SUV
allerdings keine Eigenentwicklung
sondern auf einer elektroplattform von
Volkswagen
darüber hinaus diskutieren wir auch eine
andere Plattform eine Ford eigene
Plattform in Europa zu installieren und
da gibt es sehr viel zu tun für unser
Team in der technischen Entwicklung
diese Transformation von Ford
Deutschland hin zu Elektroautos hat
begonnen und schließt betriebsbedingte
Kündigungen bis Ende 2032 aus
im August kam ein 16-Jähriger seniger
lese in Dortmund bei einem
Polizeieinsatz ums Leben jetzt hat die
Staatsanwaltschaft nach Medienberichten
Anklage gegen fünf Polizisten erhoben
der mutmaßliche Schütze muss sich nach
Angaben seines Anwalts deswegen
Totschlags verantworten die Polizisten
waren wegen Suizidgefährdung zu der
Einrichtung gerufen worden in der der
Jugendliche untergebracht war im Laufe
des Einsatzes vielen Dank die tödlichen
Schüsse aus einer Maschinenpistole
der gründungsintendant des ZDF Karl
Holzhammer hat falsche Angaben über
seine Biografie während der NS-Zeit
gemacht so das Ergebnis einer internen
Untersuchung die das ZDF im Vorfeld
seines 60-jährigen Jubiläums gemacht hat
Holzhammer 15 Jahre an der Spitze des
Senders verschwieg unter anderem seine
zeitweilige Zugehörigkeit zur sais war
die paramilitärische Kampforganisation
der NSDAP ein Bericht von Christian
Kirsch
Karl Johannes Holz armer erster
intendantes ZDF von 1962 bis 1977
intellektueller Philosoph
rundfunkjournalist geboren 1906 prägen
ihn Weltkrieg Weimarer Republik und die
NS-Zeit
holzsommer hat sich dargestellt als
System fern nur eine Anwartschaft als
Mitglied in der NSDAP habe bestanden die
habe er zurückgezogen das ist nicht
richtig diese Karteikarte belegt seine
Partei Vollmitgliedschaft ab 1938 und
die zuständige NSDAP Ortsgruppe
bescheinigt 1940 es handele sich bei
Partei genossen dr holzamer um einen
moralischen charakterlich gefestigten
Partei genossen der rückhaltlos für den
nationalsozialistischen Staat Eintritt
Recherchen ergeben holzamer war Teil der
vielfältigen Organisationsstruktur im
NS-Staat
NSDAP-Mitgliedschaft sa Mitgliedschaft
Mitgliedschaft im
nationalsozialistischen lehrerbund
von Reporter deutscher Propaganda
Kompanien holzamer war einer von ihnen
er vermeldet die Bombardierung Belgrad
durch deutsche Sturzkampfbomber
unsere modernen Waffen unsere Stukas die
beherrsche der Lüfte die sind über
Jugoslawien gewesen in diesen
Morgenstunden kurz nach der
programmation des Führers und haben hier
ihre Arbeit getan
Propaganda wie tief war der Junge
holzsamer verstrickt in das NS-Regime
der Historiker Martin Sabro ordnet ein
in gewisser Weise war heute mal ein
Mitläufer weil er keine ekstatische
Begeisterung für das NS-Regime an den
Tag legt legte und weil er sich aus
seiner relativen Distanz heraus zum NS
zum Nationalsozialismus hinbewegte er
war kein Mitläufer wenn wir darauf
achten wie seine formale Belastung
beschaffen ist das
innerstep-mitgliedsa-mitglied lässt sich
nicht als Mitläufer bezeichnen sondern
schon auch als einer der Unterstützer
des Regimes
nach dem Krieg macht Holzhammer
akademische Karriere er wird Professor
für Philosophie an der Universität Mainz
es folgen Auszeichnungen aus dem In- und
Ausland Kanzler Adenauer schätzt den
Katholiken Holzammer sehr Nachfrage zu
seiner Biografie eher nicht mit der
teils verschwiegenen persönlichen
Geschichte ließ es sich im neuen Staat
offenbar leben wir haben gerade in den
kriegsberechter Kompanien und
Kriegsberichterstatter Truppen der
Wehrmacht eine Reihe von Figuren die in
den NS-Zeit ihr journalistisches
Handwerk im Lobpreis das in s-regimes
gelernt haben und trotzdem nach 1945 zu
stützen der Demokratie wurden
das ZDF hielt seinen
gründungsintendanten bislang in Ehren
und nun ein neuer Blick auf die
Geschichte des Senders
wir machen sportlich weiter Biathlon WM
in Oberhof Norbert und weiter keine
Medaillen für die Männer ja heute beim
20 km Einzelrennen kein Podestplatz aber
eine gute Leistung von Benedikt doll als
bester DVD auf Frank 5 dafür konnten
wieder die Norwegen feiern wieder ein
doppelter Erfolg wieder allen voran der
Dominator
Johannes Tini SPÖ ist und bleibt der
überragende Athlet bei dieser WM vier
Start vier Titel
ja viel mal Gold
schöner Tag hier in Oberhof
auch heute wieder der überragende Läufer
am Schießstand zwar zwei Strafminuten
dennoch die Konkurrenz chancenlos
er kämpft sich nach einem Fehler Silber
Bronze geht an Sebastian da müssen aus
Schweden
Benedikt doll heute mit seinem besten
Rennen hier in Oberhof ein Fehler Rang
fünf Teamkollege Philipp Nawrath
überzeugt mit Platz 9
noch keine einzige deutsche Medaille
gab's bislang bei der Ski Alpin WM in
Frankreich heute im parallelen waren die
Hoffnung groß aber das deutsche Team das
scheiterte im Viertelfinale an
Olympiasieger Österreich Gold holten die
USA
unbändiger Jubel von Paula Malzer Nina
obrain Riverdale muss und Tommy Ford den
neuen Weltmeistern im alpinen
Teamwettbewerb ein unglücklicher Fehler
des Norwegers Timon haugan in der
Startbox kostet seine Mannschaft in
einem spannenden Finale gegen die USA
die Chance auf die Goldmedaille Tommy
ford bringt das letzte Duell im parallel
Riesenslalom fehlerfrei und schneller
als haugan ins Ziel Gold für die USA
Silber für Norwegen Bronze sichert sich
die Mannschaft aus Kanada nach einem
Sturz von Alexander Schmid sind für die
deutsche Mannschaft mit ihm Lena Dörr
Andrea Filser und linusstraße alle
Medaillenträume im Viertelfinale
ausgeträumt
zu den Champions League Achtelfinale die
Bayern heute in Paris morgen Dortmund
gegen Chelsea alle Spieler ausführlich
bei uns zu sehen im Sportstudio
Champions League morgen 23 Uhr heute
überraschte die UEFA mit einer
Entschuldigung laut eines unabhängigen
Kommissionsbericht sind für die Ursachen
des Chaos rund um das Champions League
Finale letzten Mai in Paris mit 238
verletzten nicht Liverpool Fans oder die
Polizei verantwortlich sondern die UEFA
und ihr Missmanagement der Verband
entschuldigt die sich deshalb
wenigstens ehrlich ja hoffen wir mal
dass die das bei diesem Finale in diesem
Jahr in Istanbul besser hinbekommen
danke schön Norbert es gibt einmal
Schmuddel und kalt und dann sonnig und
mild was morgen für Sie in Frage kommt
gleich im Wetter mit Katja horneffer
um 21 Uhr 45 empfehlen wir das heute
journal mit Marietta Slomka wir vom
gesamten 19 Uhr Team sagen Danke schönen
Abend und gerne bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend dieser Nebel an Weser und
Allah der löste sich im Laufe des Tages
rasch auf anders saß am Oberrhein aus
oder auch an der Donau da hielten sich
die Nebelfelder zäh und da kletterten
die Temperaturen kaum aus dem Frost raus
nur null Grad waren es ein Donautal mit
Sonnenschein ging's dagegen bis 16 Grad
drauf heute Nacht geht's wieder Nebel
Dunst auch eine hochnebeldecke im
Nordosten und die Temperaturen sinken
auf plus zwei bis minus 6 Grad und auch
morgen bleibt kalt dort wo es trüb
bleibt mit nur zwei Grad im Donautal mit
Sonne gibt's aber wieder Werte deutlich
über zehn Grad und auch morgen geht's
zum Teil strahlenden Sonnenschein zum
Teil aber auch sehr trübes Wetter und
diese hochnebeldecke im Nordosten dann
wird sich was ändern denn von Nordwesten
kommen Regen Wolken heran und Freitag
und Samstag wird es dann richtig
stürmisch besonders an der Küste guten
Abend